[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir les enfants mais qu'est ce que
tu as nounours fin patron j'ai faim le
ce soir on va se régaler en famille on
va se faire une bonne petite soupe d'eau
court bien bio tueur j'espère que tu as
une bonne recette
la recette de ma tante gabi aux patrons
j'en ai l'eau à la bouche ou le seul 9
pouces voir ce jeune homme
qu'est ce qui t'a parquet c'est un
ballon chaud quand ma mère une partie de
rugby c'est papa long c'est une course
je m'en vais vous préparez une
délicieuse petite soupe de cours et
c'est pas m c'est un petit rond c'est la
même chose m'attendent tapis elle
appelle ça une coûts et notre temps du
style elle dit que c'était un petit rond
oui bon et bien outre al les enfants au
vous pressez être chef
voilà votre chapeau chef
merci mon petit là je pose la courge et
voilà de quoi avez vous besoin h f une
grande casserole plein d'eau sucrée pour
commencer de l'eau bien jo vrai h f
merci on prend le potiron par surprise
voilà et on le plonge dedans et à
présent on fait bouillir jusqu'à ce que
le potiron soit bien temps puis on le
coupe aux petits morceaux
[Musique]
qu'est ce qui est drôle
bon d'accord je pâtiront comme à bâle
ont enlevé la vie du feu voyons voir
c'est vrai elle accouche simple détail
les enfants remettez la sur le feu et
ajouter de l'eau froide pour la calmer
à thé de frags ça y est parfait vous
allez voir tout va redevenir normale
[Musique]
le tu d'accord je tire où elle est tout
petit il reste presque rien fait voir
tiens regarde pour mon dieu on la remet
dans laquelle sera oui
ajoutez un peu de sucre oui c'est ça du
sucre à l'eau qu'est ce que ce soit beau
bizarre très bizarre tenir au courant il
épelle moutons mon dieu
tiens regarde il est dur comme du bois
le mister ladesou au labo thani et bannu
entre laisse avec ta mode annick et on
va s'coucher bonne nuit le nord est bon
appétit il faudra que je téléphone à
matane kebs pour lui demander la recette
exacte
[Musique]
alors nounours vous vous êtes bien
régalé ma recette est loupée patron
tenue regardez ce que ça a donné que
c'est joli il bravo nounours tu es très
habile vous trouvez oui tu as réussi un
charmant bibelots que tu vas mettre dans
sa vitrine aux murs supporteront vous me
mettez du baume sur le corps allons en
route grands cuisiniers bonne nuit les
enfants fêtes de bourg eux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]